another gorgeous day at the coliseum as
we get set for the third and final game
of the series the a's and the giants a's
have dominated i mean dominated the
first two games of the series winning
both games my final scores of six to
nothing so plenty of offense the
pitching's been terrific and mike miner
will be starting for the athletics and
there is hope there at least talk about
frankie montage maybe making the start
but he and his wife
had a little bit of a baby delivery so
mike miner
is starting for the athletics he started
against the giants back on july the 31st
as a member of the texas rangers and did
not do well in that game that was over
in san francisco so mike miter pitching
well for the athletics and hopes to
continue that today against the giants
slater hits one in the air to right
field toward the corner biscotti
makes the catch
3-2 pitch foul tip and that's the
strikeout
on the hill today for the giants will be
the left-handed veteran tyler anderson
anderson in his
fifth year at the big league level
that's what he has done this year two
and three with a five zero six era 33
strikeouts against 18 walks you take
your bats against him you're going to
see a fastball that can go low to mid
90s more lows than mids he's going to
sink and cut that fastball
he's got a curveball and a changeup and
he'll throw any of those pitches in any
count
simeon hitting 232 with seven home runs
and he got him
good change up
two and two to mauricio dubois he's a
right-handed hitter it's on the way
minor throws it's swung on a foul tip
held by murphy and that is strike three
and mike miner so far
so good retires the first six batters
that he's faced and after one and a half
it's the a's and the giants nothing
nothing olson left-handed batter
got him three pitches you saw the target
from chadwick trump on that o2 pitch
they wanted to go above the hands
they know olson the tall guy low ball
hitter he's got a weakness upstairs on
fastballs you couldn't throw it better
and here's chadwick trump
trump hits a high drive to left and out
of here
he dug that one out and it's two nothing
that's number four for chadwick trump
well he went down and got this one so he
pumped that one out at 108.
he just tee it up right there at the
knee middle end
looked like he was on the first tee at
winged foot this morning rough in a line
drive to cannon in left field that was
caught the pitch
swung on driven to center lauriana
breaking back toward the track near the
wall and gone
right over the 400-foot sign
darren ruff powers one out his fifth of
the year
with belt aboard and the giants have
doubled their lead to four nothing and
that was on an o2 pitch so trump beat
him one two
ruff wins the battle at 0-2 today that's
one that miner's going to think about
think about it he threw it a no-one
fastball right by him he was laid on and
he comes back with a breaking ball
right in the middle of the zone right
now it's davis at third laureano at
first two down anderson sets
delivers
swing and a ground ball to beld it first
big
one hopper he takes it to the bag for
the out and
tyler addison has brought it through the
storm
back into port
safely and devon dumps the single and
the giants have the bases loaded with
one out and crawford's coming up
now crawford he swings and he blasts one
high and deep to right field way back
there and arios
pelota
and it's a grand slam and the giants
have busted it wide open how about that
that's got to feel pretty good for
brandon crawford we have a word for that
do we not ambush and one thing the
giants are not going to take for granted
that they've scored enough runs today a
93 mile out fastball an opportunity for
the ace to get back in the game lefty
versus lefty base is loaded for oakland
and there's a line drive base in right
field
that's gonna score two davis is gonna go
to third and the a's are on the board so
jake glam against the left-hander with a
two-out two-run single
well you gotta love this if you're jake
lamb we've talked about doing those
little things heading into october
two out knocks we've been in scoring
position check
on one for three giants lead eight to
two but hoping for something more here
three and oh two dubon
weems pitches and he misses ball four
dubon takes the walk it's nine to two
giants so crawford gets a chance to hit
another one
3-2 pitch runners go swing and a miss
got him on the split and the inning is
over but a bases low to walk brings home
a run for the giants we stretch to the
coliseum 9-2 san francisco 1-1 to rough
bases loaded 201. 1-1 pitch swing off
the end of the bat a sinking liner into
left center field base head the giants
now lead 11-2 a two-run single for ruff
he's got four rbis today and here's
female machine coming up
[Applause]
tap slowly going to be a tough play
and that's the ball game the giants beat
the athletics finally
for the
only time this year